it was that time again
apple's superlative mania or what the
company calls its worldwide developers
conference
at the virtual event the company
announced updates to our new release is
ios 15. watch os
ipad west 15 mac os monterey the updates
are coming this fall to all your gadgets
and of course apple highlighted all the
features as
the incredible incredible incredible but
not everything can be
incredible and great and the best
because well
that's not how it works here's my list
of what i actually think will be the
best features
plus a few nods to what's more on the
math side
number one improved zoom features i mean
facetime
but you can understand the confusion
since facetime in the upcoming ios
ipad os and mac os upgrades has a grid
view
and blurred backgrounds and noise
cancellation me too
let me fix this better right
just like zoom but what zoom doesn't
have is share play
this facetime feature lets you watch
video or listen to a song with the
person on the other end of the call
for video sharing it will work with
disney plus hulu tick tock and more
seems exciting but oh netflix where
aren't that
also big facetime links which lets you
send a link to others to join a facetime
call
even if they're on android or windows
number two
focus features focus is a new way to
match your device
to your current mindset now you can set
a mode to block out notifications you
don't want to see during different times
of the day
you set this up and can customize what
gets through
apple will also use on-device learning
to suggest apps and people to let
through
or block during those times frankly it
all looks a bit confusing
even better when you put your device in
do not disturb it can inform
others that you're busy just like an old
school away message
number three find my airpods pro and max
sorry no regular airpods for this those
now work with apple's find my network
which means
your airpods simply send out a secure
bluetooth beacon that can be detected by
other apple devices
they can relay your airpods location to
the network and then back to your find
my app if you lose them close by
you can play the sound and use the
proximity feature to find them
plus there's a new separation alert if
you leave your airpods behind
number four driver's license so your
apple wallet has already had your credit
cards or your transit cards
now it can have your driver's license
this fall
you'll just scan your driver's license
or state id in participating u.s states
but that's the big question what are the
participating u.s dates
apple wouldn't say yet apple says the
tsa is also working to accept this
so you could use your phone's id at the
airport pretty cool
number five weather don't lie you use
your iphone's weather app possibly more
than
any other app and you know it can be a
lot better the new version will have
full weather maps and we'll make sure
it's always sunny wherever you are just
joking on that last part apple has a lot
of power
but not that much power number six
easier ipad multitasking
you no longer need to remember some
combo of secret swipes to multitask on
an ipad
an icon shows up at the top of the
screen where you can tap to put
something on the side of the screen or
in full screen mode
number seven on device speech
recognition
siri can now do a lot more launch apps
control music
change settings without ever using an
internet connection
because it processes all the information
on the device
as long as you have a recent iphone or
ipad that means that those tasks should
be a lot faster too
it definitely looked a lot faster in
apple's recorded demos
open photos
[Music]
open calendar i will have to try that
out for myself
number eight digital legacy this one is
near and dear to my heart
a new feature in the apple id controls
will let you assign a legacy contact
so if you were to die that person could
access your apple account
including photos and other information
this is something other companies
including google and facebook have had
for a while
number nine safari tab groups
in mac os monterey and ios 15 safari
lets you group tabs together
so say you have a bunch of tabs you want
to save around your next trip
you can save them on this sidebar i use
a similar feature in microsoft's edge
browser and i love it this really may
get me to go back to safari
and speaking of safari and ios 15 the
address bar is moved to the bottom
that's going to take some getting used
to number 10
lots of privacy it's hard to pick just
one privacy feature there's a new
service called private relay that
encrypts all your traffic in safari
to get it you have to pay for another
icloud service though which is called
icloud plus another that doesn't cost
extra
the app privacy report which is located
in settings
you can see how often apps use the
permission you've granted
to access your location photos
camera microphone contacts and more
during the last seven days
that sort of stuff used to require
special software to see so yeah those
are my top picks
but some of the other stuff like
improved photos on a tiny tiny watch
screen
or a feature that tells me when to get
off the train
or interactive memories where you can
add music to photos for a
instant video i'm not so sure
i look forward to testing it all before
these operating systems are released in
the fall
in the meantime just remember every
feature cannot be
the best best best fast fast